you are robotic chic right now I really
am I really am I like it
I dig the color I think the color I love
it now how does it make you feel I mean
you were up doing impressions of people
then so many people grew up doing
impressions with you I mean I did I was
the kid at the party the fire marshal
bill yeah no no I was I don't want to
see that oh yes behavioral disorders
that's not really an impression here it
goes but how does that make you feel
that a new crop of kids are gonna see
this character get attached
I get so gratified by that you know the
idea that there may be a new Halloween
costume you know what I mean because all
the way along there's been kind of
decades now where I seem to have really
been lucky enough to kind of be graced
with characters that that keep
reintroducing themselves the new
generations of people so I know I have
the 40 year old come up to me and say
hey I grew up with you and I have the
little 10 year old come up to me and
saying I'm about to grow up with you
like Tiger did the math yeah it's a
little risky how do you approach the
character like robotic as you go you go
full gym very well you know with
characters you know they seem like they
just come out of the ether you know like
a bolt of lightning but they're actually
Lightning is born from the ground up so
you know you got to know where the
character is coming from when you look
at the videogame there's none of that
fleshed out that's the challenge you
know so for me it's it's really about
the unloved you know my saying is be
where the unloved you know because they
will hurt themselves or someone else you
know what I mean so in this case it
manifested in him trying to own the
world
yeah and trying to create avatars of
himself that you can't avoid you know so
I love the whole concept is cool to me
I love that now okay so many iconic
characters that we all love it's hard
not to bring them up I should say also
when he sees sonic I'm sorry to
interrupt when he sees sonic when
Robotnik sees sonic it's like seeing
that missing part of him you know it's
that it personification of the missing
part of Robotnik which is that childlike
electric joy in play you know and I say
that he's got a he's got a sonic shaped
hole in his heart you know and he'll
never be able to have that for himself
and he wants to hold it so badly in
Sonic so like he's got the world ahead
of him he's got this whole bucket list
what is on Jim Carrey's 2020 bucket list
I just want to be the best darn Catholic
that I can be
[Music]